so in our last video about the age of
apocalypse we had run over the various
factions of the x-men related groups and
their various missions which were
assigned them by magneto what we do now
is we transition away from all of that
and we focus on two other groups the
first group is Jean Grey and Wolverine
and the second group is Nate gray now
starting with Wolverine and Jean Grey as
we discussed in our first video that you
were actually a romantic couple
whether also agents of the human High
Council we initially pickup with the duo
as they're using sentinels to help ferry
humans from North America to England
after the group had basically destroyed
apocalypses Atlantic defense system for
the purpose of launching a nuclear
strike against apocalypse in North
America however what we learn is that
there's actually a rogue group of
mutants that have made their way and
more or less kind of blended into these
humans by masquerading as humans
themselves and so what happens here is
that these mutants once they're on the
other side basically begin attacking the
weapons depot which would render the
guidance systems and the nuclear weapons
themselves absolutely useless during the
conflict Wolverine realizes that Jean is
leaving the area and travelling back to
North America and so is attempt to try
to figure out what it is that she's
doing Wolverine tracks her down only to
learn that G's in tension is to
basically attempt to stop the nuclear
attack by warning various groups within
with America itself and so after being
given the choice as to either kill Jean
Grey or let her go
Wolverine elects to let her leave
resulting in Jean racing toward North
America as Wolverine basically watches
the preparations being made for the
nuclear strike against North America and
apocalypse and so what we do from here
is jump to make gray now again in the
previous video we had talked about how
Nate gray was the offspring of Jean Grey
and Scott Summers and was created using
the genetic material of the two by mr.
sinister during Jean Grey's time in the
breeding pens although all of this is
actually unknown to Nate gray himself in
addition a sinister had eventually found
a gray and joined his group under the
guise of having the desire to destroy
apocalypse and his minions however what
we find here is that sinister has
actually been subtly manipulating Nate
gray and having a desire to kill
apocalypse personally and this
actually something that's discovered by
forge who acts as a kind of father
figure to Nate gray and so in Forge
confront sinister about his plans
sinister simply mortally injured Forge
and so eventually forges body is
discovered by nae gray and forges dying
words are to basically instruct Nate
gray to go find magneto because magneto
will know what to do but before Nate
gray can actually leave to find magneto
he's discovered by sinister who gives me
great his entire history what we learn
here is that during their time in the
breeding pens Scott Summers and Jean
Grey seem to have engaged in a coupling
now how it was that sinister was able to
gain the genetic material of Jean Grey
and Scott Summers is unknown here but
what we do know is that once the genetic
material was gained that mr. sinister
basically began the process of trying to
find a way to create a cloned using the
genetic material of the to which he was
successful in doing but once the clone
was made that Cyclops had basically
broken broken x-man out of the out of
the facility out of the science facility
that was owned by mr. sinister and so
from there it seemed as though x-man was
simply just discovered by forge and has
a result force just kind of allowed Nate
grey to basically develop his memory so
more or less just kind of come into his
own and so what happens is that due to
the culmination of sinister having
killed forge we due to the fact that
Nate gray had lost so many of his
friends he basically lashes out and
actually kills sinister in the process
and so what happens is Nate gray
basically sets out to try to find to
allocate and kill apocalypse and so what
we're gonna find here is that all of
these stories the story of Nate gray the
story of Wolverine and Jean Grey the
story of Cyclops and the x-men in
magneto and all these things are going
to culminate in this final issue of the
Age of Apocalypse called x-men Omega
where we'll see this massive battle
taking place and presumably the
destruction of this entire reality with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later peace
yeah man in the mirror picking up the
Beast shelf what the beep sneaking off a
true balance tell me what's up
two minutes chump lush long long enough
to reach enough heights mesh bottom
between precious world from the goblins
don't wake up press the heavy the liquid
man to get on